this bar is packed I think I'm fine so
how do you feel about the whole foaming
each other doing PDA in public thing I
don't know how I feel about it I guess
I'm a little nervous about it but at the
same time excited because it's not like
it's not something we ever do but it's
something we should be able to do I'm a
little scared to be honest I've never
had experiences like that per se but
last week this man started following me
from my car all the way to the
apartments yelling out [ __ ] so what
would be your best-case scenario during
this best-case scenario would be getting
kind of completely ignored no looks no
nothing just like blending in then what
would be your worst case scenario the
big one that like is very obvious as
somebody gets violent or overly
aggressive our first date was a tropical
storm it was a hurricane that downgraded
to a tropical storm and everybody in
Florida freaked out and shut down all
the businesses the only thing open was a
Starbucks so we went to Starbucks and we
sat down for six hours and just talked
there it was just the most natural
conversation I've really ever had with
anybody
since that first date we got engaged we
moved to Los Angeles and we have two
animals dog and a cat not doing PDA and
stuff is not from our families because
our families have been nothing but
loving and accepting and caring towards
us but it has been a lot towards just
experiences from the outside world
[Music]
day one today you guys can visit any
public space with a sidewalk once there
we need you guys to kiss once he kiss
you may sit on the sidewalk and read the
second page how public have a space
every time you yeah I don't know okay so
we've literally like switch spots 5,000
times the last one I saw an Army veteran
and I didn't want him to get mad
he was an Army veteran yeah I had an
Army veteran hat is that respectful that
we didn't do it in front of him or is it
silly that we didn't dude I don't
technically fought for our rights okay
ready
I read
okay I guess it's time to read the
letter yeah lady in the car wave in
April 2015
Zachary Johnson and Casey Williams were
attacked by Stewart Butler in Huntington
West Virginia after Butler saw them
kissing on the sidewalk Butler was
arrested and faced with misdemeanor
assault charges but courts ruled that it
was not a hate crime because sexual
orientation is not protected
they literally just did the same exact
thing and that outcome that they
experienced
the reason we were so hesitant to do
this in the first place and the reason
we've changed so many locations today
you can go out to the mall or a
restaurant holding hands there having
done both you may read the second page
when we go out to dinner we sit across
from each other yeah talk we don't ever
sit on the same side so as not to
disturb other diners I don't think about
like normal people typically sit next to
each other unless they're like normal
people
normally I don't know well case a
heterosexual competitor or sexual
couples see we're part of the problem
you are part of the problem we're normal
yeah the best part is that no one's even
like acknowledging yeah this they're
just going about their lives we I mean
there's a few scientists but I think
that's just like normal because I'm
giving people side glances to they're
doing it too
he scared you down let's see what
today's fact is okay in July 2018 in
Seattle caster Kwok assaulted a man for
holding hands with another man he was
derogatory language spit in the man's
face and stabbed him following a
physical altercation it's reported he
told police that he assaulted the men
because they were gay quack face it
faces hate crime charges how do you feel
about um I'm walking around the mall and
yeah going to dinner and this time I
felt more comfortable like I didn't
really have a panic like I did yesterday
I think it's just the environment the
more I do this the more I realize that
it's so silly
we're glancing around like is anybody
gonna give me problems if I try to do
this it's so silly but it's silly the
fact that we have to do it it's not
silly that we're doing no it's silly
that we have to do it necessarily that
we're doing what we're doing it for
safety we have to make that distinction
because like although I enjoy the fact
that I have kissing you at the throat
and stuff like that I'm still very aware
of how dangerous it is of course and
this is in Los Angeles yeah and this
imagine like in other places today you
guys need to go to a straight bar and
hold hands once you held hand and are
seated you may kiss briefly this one
might be a little bit more scary than
just standing on the sidewalk yeah a
little more risque does a wine bar count
as a straight bar I feel like they want
us to walk in holding hands and go take
a seat oh no it's Sunday football oh
that's gonna be interesting
do this open hands and we go alright
let's just go go going upstairs
what's going on
it's really
practice guide on our pike
I think I ran out of the design
[Music]
walked in holding him and then the
minute we got to the bar section we let
go all right so I'm a recording
Christian but sweetly recording the
couple behind us who seems to have no
trouble weighing on each other
and we're here stressing over holding
hands and kissing each other in public
nobody blew up in flames the place is
still intact
well there was some people who turned
around and left
but they didn't say anything yeah but
they did like stare and then they kept
on checking back to see where we're
gonna do it I have a lot of anxiety
especially when it comes to the sport
it's the type of things I was an athlete
as a kid and I hung out with like three
people until like high school and when I
came out one of them tried beating me up
because people assumed that we were
together because I came out of the
closet well let's read this no in 2009
Justin Goodwin an openly gay man was
mocked with homophobic language and
beaten by a group of male assailants
outside a bar following the attack
during which his jaw eye-sockets and
cheek bones were broken he had his face
surgically reassembled in seven hours of
surgery he killed himself in 2011 which
his lawyers argue was a result of the
trauma he incurred during the attack of
course it was yeah I'm seeing a pattern
our biggest fear here in Los Angeles is
that someone will say something to us
and there's people in other parts of the
country and world whose biggest fear is
beheaded hung thrown off a building this
isn't happening in the 50s isn't
happening in the forties this isn't
happening in 2011 the last one was 2015
I'm sorry I'm just really anxious this
was just a lie it was I love you I
really do what I love him so much and
we've been together for so long and I
feel like we have the most amazing
relationship but still moments like this
moments in public it's so scary for me I
thought that like I can have him taken
away because some little phobic and at
scared of that I'm scared that because
I'm a standard so it's gonna take it for
me
[Music]
you
[Music]